Wireless Fantasy by Vladimir
Ussachevsky. It's one of the first
pieces of computer-generated music.
It was done at Columbia University
in 1960. It was commissioned by a
group of fans of Lee de Forest,
and it was in honor of de Forest's
contribution to wireless broadcast.
And one of the first broadcasts de
Forest ever sent over the radio was
the piece that you are hearing.
It's Parsifal.
It is from the Wagner Opera.
And so what Ussachevsky has done in
the piece is to process it to make
it sound really distanct as though
it is coming over a shortwave radio.
And then he has Morse Code, and
there is various Morse Code messages
going through the piece.
Wireless Fantasy, from 1960,
done long-hand, by the way. It was
really done with Morse Code in a
mainframe computer and giant
reel-to-reel decks.
Nothing like what you have on your
desktop today.
OK, so announcements.
Tomorrow will be the exceptional
Thursday, quiz five based on
homework five.
Last day we talked about the band
theory of solids.
And, in the band theory,
we were able to distinguish metals
from insulators from semi-conductors.
And you can see up here,
the metal has a very, very tiny
energy gap between the top of the
filled orbitals and the bottom of
the unfilled orbitals.
So it is effortless to move the
electron up into this zone and give
it mobility. In an insulator,
there is a substantial energy
required to move from the filled
orbitals to the unfilled orbitals,
which we neatly refer to as the
valence band and conduction band.
And, arbitrarily, we have chosen
three electron volts.
Typically the insulators are up
four, five, six and so
on electron volts.
And then there is this class of
material semiconductors for which
the band gap is on the order of
three electron volts.
And why is three such a magic
number? Because three electrons
volts is the threshold of visible
light. Materials that have energy
gaps below three electron volts will
respond to visible light,
and we are going to talk about such
matters presently.
And just the last point to make is
that the valence band is constructed
of the splitting of orbitals that
are associated with bonding.
Valence band is valence electrons in
bonding orbitals,
and the conduction band was
generated from antibonding orbitals.
And then we looked at
photoexcitation.
If we have incident photons that
have enough energy to break the bond,
electrons will be promoted up into
the conduction band.
And it is a momentary transit.
And they will subsequently cascade
back down. And,
when they do so, a photon will be
reemitted. When the electron
cascades down, a photon
will be emitted.
And the emission will be pegged at
the band gap energy.
If we go into hc over lambda,
lambda becomes a critical value that
is associated with this particular
material. And so we can plot
percent absorption.
Percent absorption of what?
Percent absorption of incident
light as a function of the energy of
that incident light.
High wavelength, low energy light
will pass through.
It will be transmitted,
and the material will appear
transparent.
High energy, that is to say low
wavelength incident radiation will
have enough energy to promote
electrons. And so,
therefore, those incident photons
will be absorbed,
the excess energy will be dissipated
up here as heat,
and then we will get reemission of
photons. And so,
over here, the material is an
absorber. And so we have a sharp
jump here at a critical wavelength
which we termed the "absorption
edge." And then,
towards the end of the lecture,
we talked about another type of
excitation. This was
photoexcitation.
We are going to talk about thermal
excitation, where the thermal energy
in the environment is enough to
cause the breaking of the bonds and
the promotion of the electron from
the valence band to the conduction
band. But, in this case,
we discovered that pair of carriers
was generated.
Not a single carrier.
In the case of photoexcitation,
the electron moves up, falls back
down. Here we have pair excitation.
What happens is this electron is
permanently sustainably sitting up
in the valence band leaving in its
place a broken bond which consists
of a single electron and a missing
electron which is termed a "hole."
It is zero in a land of minus one,
so it appears to be plus one. And
this is minus one in a land of zero,
so it appears to be minus one. You
see charge conservation.
The population of electrons in the
conduction band due to thermal
excitation is equal to the
population of holes in the valence
band. And electrical engineers like
to just refer to the nature of the
charge, regardless of the carrier.
Whether it is a positive ion or a
positive hole,
as far as they are concerned it is a
positive. The electrical engineers
write this relationship n equals p.
The number of negative charges in
the conduction band equals the
number of positive charges in the
valence band. And then I left you
with this mystery at the end of the
lecture. I said,
well, we observe thermal excitation
in semiconductors but the thermal
energy is roughly related to the
product of the Boltzmann constant
times the temperature.
And, in electron volts,
this amounts to about one-fortieth
of an electron volt at room
temperature. But the band gap
energy in semiconductors is on the
order of several electron volts.
In the case of silicon, it is 1.
electron volts. How can we justify
any kind of thermal excitation given
that the thermal energy is so much
lower than that of the band gap
energy? Well, I have good news.
The answer is that the energy in
this room is distributed amongst all
of the entities in the room so that
if you look at the gas,
for example, let's go back to the
1850s and peer into the mind of
James Clark Maxwell who also gave us
Maxwell's equations.
He was a polymath like so many of
the other people that we have been
talking about in 3.
91. He didn't just focus on
electromagnetism. He was
a renaissance scholar.
And one of his areas of interest was
physical chemistry,
and he studied gases.
He reasoned that the gases have a
distribution of velocities.
All of the gas molecules in this
room are not behaving as though they
are at room temperature.
A substantial number are,
and that is how we establish
temperature, but what Maxwell
reasoned was that some gas molecules
are moving around as though the
temperature of the room is 500
Kelvin, and some are moving around
as though it is only 100 Kelvin,
but a large number of them are
moving around as though it
is roughly 300 Kelvin.
He gave us a mathematical
formulation of the distribution of
energies. And then,
about 25 years later,
Boltzmann came along and said I am
going to going to generalize the
idea. Forget about just gas
molecules and velocity.
Let's talk about all molecules and
say the reason the gas molecules are
moving mainly at 300 Kelvin and that
some are moving at 500 Kelvin is --
And this was a big leap for
Boltzmann. He said I am going to
propose that temperature is
distributed as well.
That the reason some gas molecules
are moving as though they have the
velocity of 500 Kelvin is that I am
going to propose that they have the
energy of 500 Kelvin.
What is local energy?
That is temperature. Maxwell and
Boltzmann, we put the two of them
together and we come up with the
notion of a distribution of
temperature, distribution of energy.
And this is what that distribution
looks like.
What we do is we plot the number of
particles in a particular ensemble
that have a particular energy as a
function of energy.
And then we will normalize it over
the total number of particles in the
system. Before I do that,
why don't I just do an analogy?
We had the test a few weeks ago.
Let's do a distribution of grades,
and then we will relate it. For
example, what I could do is plot
grade on this axis and I could put
the number of people who have a
particular grade and
then normalize it.
Divide it by the total number of
students in the class.
If it's a big class, as this one is,
and we have some kind of reasonable
test, we expect to see this kind of
a distribution.
A bell-shaped curve.
A Gaussian distribution.
What does this tell us? It tells
us that some people had greater than
the average value.
Some people had less than the
average value,
but the average value is given here.
It is a symmetric distribution.
And so we can call this the average.
This is the average grade, g with a
bar over it. And you get the
inflection point here.
This is where the second derivative
shifts from positive to negative.
That is how you get the standard
deviation. This is g bar plus
standard deviation.
This is g bar minus standard
deviation. You can have a lot of
fun with this.
And the area under this line,
if I use normalized values, must
equal one. Area equals one when I
normalize from zero to infinity.
Let's do the same thing here,
only - this is Gaussian. But that's
not the way molecules are
distributed or energies are
distributed in ensemble.
It is asymmetrical. It looks a
little bit like this.
It has a sharp rise and a long
asymptotic tail.
And so the average is not at the
maximum in this case. This
is Maxwell-Boltzmann.
We have a distribution of energies.
And the energy average, E with a
macron over it,
is somewhere a little bit to the
right of the maximum.
And so what I am doing is taking
the energy of a particle,
the number of particles of a given
energy divided by the total number
of particles. Also the area under
this curve must equal one.
This is the value at T1. And what
I want to do is focus down here.
Suppose up here this is 1.1 eV.
Well, the average value is here.
And I said that this was
one-fortieth of an electron volt.
That is not the problem. The
problem is not that the average is
one-fortieth of an electron volt.
The good news is that there is some
tiny fraction of the distribution
that has energy above 1.
eV. If I knew what that fraction
was then I could guess how much I
could expect in the wave
promotion here.
You can see it is non-zero.
It is not a sharp cutoff. There is
a tiny value out here.
And the nature of this curve is
that the fraction of the
distribution out here,
if I want to integrate,
say, from 1.1 eV out to infinity,
that is the area under this line,
what am I integrating?
I am integrating the fraction times
dE. This equals e to the minus
energy gap divided by k Boltzmann
temperature, this exponential.
That is what gives us the fraction
underneath this line.
Now let's see what happens when
temperature rises.
When temperature rises this line
shifts to the right.
And, as you would expect,
the average shifts to the right as
well. This now is E average at T2.
Let's say I raise the temperature.
Let's look at silicon. Let's say
T1 is equal to room temperature 300
Kelvin, and T2 will be the melting
point of silicon.
T2 is the melting point of silicon.
Not to make liquid silicon. It is
solid silicon at the melting point.
It would be like ice at zero
degrees C. Melting point of silicon
is 1414 degrees C.
Add 273 to it and you get about
1700 Kelvin. What is the ratio?
T2 to T1 is on the order of about
six. This thing shifts by a factor
of six. Let's look at what happens
in here. I am going to blow this up.
What we are really looking at is
what's the difference between the
area here at room temperature?
What we are going to do is not to
scale. Then we are going to look at
the area under the green curve.
And when we use this relationship,
E to the minus energy gap energy
over kT, band gap energy over kT,
we find that the fraction at T2
divided by the fraction at T1 comes
out to be 10 to the 15th.
Changing temperature changes the
excitation population through the
shift in the high end of the curve.
And it is only through that that we
end up seeing decent levels of
population in the conduction band.
Actually, the number at room
temperature is vanishingly small.
At room temperature the fraction in
the conduction band is about 10 to
the minus 19th.
There are so few of them you can
give each of them a name.
There is almost no conduction.
Silicon at room temperature is an
insulator. If we want to get some
conductivity are we going to heat
our computers up to such a high
temperature? I don't think so.
We need some other way of
populating the conduction band.
And we are going to do one other
mode of promotion.
We've looked at photoexcitation,
thermal excitation, and the third
mode is chemoexcitation.
What we are going to do is get
carrier injection by introducing
impurities. And I know you are
sitting there thinking he is crazy.
We just spent all of this time and
money making silicon six-nines
purity, and now we are going to
start throwing impurities into it.
Well, there are two kinds of
impurities in this world.
There are good impurities and bad
impurities. The good impurities are
called dopants.
These are the ones that are there
desirably.
Dopants are good guys.
And then there are other ones that
are called contaminants,
and these are undesirable impurities.
We don't want contaminants.
We are going to look at dopants.
And this is a really important
lesson right now that I am teaching
you. What I am showing you,
for the first time in 3.091, is how
we can use chemistry to alter the
performance of a material.
I am going to take plain
high-purity silicon,
which is an insulator at room
temperature.
And, by operating on its chemical
composition, give it properties that
it cannot possess otherwise.
This is a paradigm for solid state
chemistry. You want something that
has a higher yield strength?
We will change its composition.
You want something that has a
higher connectivity?
We will change its composition.
That is different. This is an
engineered material. And
how is it engineered?
What we are getting is via chemical
change, purposeful chemical change.
We are getting, if you would like,
tailored composition to give
targeted properties.
And this is what underlies material
science. If you don't see
what you like, make it.
And how do you make it?
By understanding the relationship
between electronic structure,
bonding and ultimately properties.
Here is what the gambit is. I am
going to talk only about elemental
semiconductors.
In the case of silicon and
germanium, I am just going to
restrict today to silicon and
germanium. That is not such a bad
restriction since we are in the
silicon age. All of your micro
devices contain silicon.
This is pretty good.
Here is the gambit. You introduce
aliovalent impurities.
What do I mean by aliovalent?
Alio is the same as the Latin world
for alias, other.
We are going to introduce
impurities that have a difference
valence from silicon and germanium.
Silicon and germanium are Group IV,
or Group 14 if you want to use IUPAC
notation. What I am going to do is
introduce something else,
and I will give you an example.
And the purpose of introducing
aliovalent impurities is to cause
electron donation or electron
consumption. And how is that going
to work? Well,
you will see it best in action.
Here is a simple example. Let's
put phosphorus in silicon.
Phosphorus, as you know, is Group
15 or Group V,
so it has five valence electrons.
And let's first look at the
Cartesian world.
Here is silicon.
It is sp3 hybridized.
And it forms a diamond-like solid.
It is crystalline, it is regular
arrays, silicons at all of the
corners of the tetrahedron,
and on and on it goes. I will give
about three of these.
Now what happens if I introduce
phosphorus?
If I introduce phosphorus,
the phosphorus actually goes in and
substitutes for silicon.
The phosphorus substitutes.
It does not go and sit in some void
space. It actually substitutes for
silicon. Now,
if it is going to substitute for
silicon it has to form bonds.
You cannot just sit there. There
is no passive observer here.
If you want to play you have got to
bond. Phosphorus comes in with five
valence electrons.
It goes one, two,
three, four. There are four of its
valence electrons bonding to the
four adjacent silicons.
What happens to the fifth valence
electron of phosphorus?
There is no empty orbital in which
that fifth electron can sit.
That fifth electron is sitting here
kind of tapping its foot wondering
what it's going to do.
Let's go over to the energy level
diagram. Here is the energy level
diagram. This is elemental silicon.
Downstairs is valence band.
Upstairs is conduction band.
When we put the phosphorus into the
silicon in energy space,
where is the only place that fifth
electron can go?
There is no room at the inn down
here. All of the valence orbitals
are filled, so the only place it can
go is up here in the conduction band.
Here is the electron that came from
phosphorus. It was donated from
phosphorus. We call phosphorus a
donor. This is a donor electron.
And can you see that every time I
throw a phosphorus in I am going to
get an extra electron in the
conduction band?
If I want to increase the
conductivity of silicon,
just keep adding phosphorus one for
one. Am I making holes down here?
No, I am not breaking any bonds.
In fact, I am forming bonds here.
There is an extra electron.
Everything is fine.
Now I have got a lever.
I can dial in how much conductivity
I want.
You want to raise the conductivity
to a certain value?
I can tell you how much phosphorus
to add to get to that level of
conductivity. And this electron is
not in a valence band.
It is not bound so it can move.
This goes back to Paul Drude.
These electrons are free to roam
because they are not bound.
I am going to show you something
really cool. How far can that
electron roam? Think about it.
Phosphorus is five valent so it has
an extra proton,
too. This phosphorus is a five plus
in a land of four plus.
The phosphorus you can think of as
locally plus. And this electron
that did not go into any of the
valence band orbitals,
it is locally minus. Duh,
an electron is locally minus,
that is deep. I have the phosphorus
that is locally plus and I have the
electron that is locally minus.
Do you know of a model that might
describe the motion of an anchored
positive charge with an electron
that is free to roam?
Do you know of a model that might
talk about such things?
Bohr. Let's do something really
whacked. Suppose we took this
electron and said let's ask the
question, if we applied the Bohr
model to this pair what would we
come up with? It is going to give
us energies. It is going to give us
radii. It is going to
give us velocities.
Do you think there might be a
relationship to velocity and
mobility and conductivity?
Well, let's see where it goes.
What I am going to do is say recall
in atomic hydrogen the ground state
energy, this is the electron at the
bottom, is minus k,
what we have been calling k,
which has this full-blown formula of
me to the 4th over eight epsilon
zero squared h squared.
Plug in all the numbers and you get
minus 13.6 electron volts.
Now, let's think about this.
We are going to have to make a few
changes. Epsilon zero,
that is the permittivity of vacuum.
But if you are an electron, you are
looking down at the phosphorus,
it is not just vacuum between you
and the central phosphorus.
There is all this stuff.
There are bonds. There is silicon
nuclei. I have got to modify this.
I have got to change this. What I
am going to do is take epsilon zero,
which is what we have for vacuum,
and I am going to replace it with
epsilon of silicon.
Silicon is the host crystal.
What does this capture? It
captures all the bonds,
all of the silicon, all of the stuff.
That is the dielectric constant of
the host crystal.
And there is one other thing.
This is some esoteric physics.
I am just going to put it up here
without proof.
When you are in this situation,
you don't use the rest mass. There
is an effective mass,
and that invokes a slight correction.
The effective mass of the electron
at the bottom of the
conduction band.
This is a minor correction.
The main correction is getting the
dielectric constant.
The second one is there for
completeness. Some of you are going
to look back fondly at these notes
and say we got it,
this was good. Otherwise,
you will say Sadoway left out the
effective mass.
You cannot say that now.
Here are the values. For silicon
the dielectric constant is 11.
and the effective mass at the
bottom of the conduction band is
one-fifth of the rest mass.
I am going to plug these values into
this equation.
And what this gives me is then that
the ground state energy of the donor
electron is minus K,
as we had before, and it is going to
be multiplied by 0.
on the top, and then I am going to
have an 11.7 squared on the bottom.
And that gives me minus 0.02
electron volts.
Two one-hundredths of electron volt.
This quantity has been measured.
The measured value compare with c.
. 0.045 eV measured. You might say
that is more than double that.
And I will say wait a minute, we
started at 13.
and I took it down to 0.
2. And you are telling me but the
real value is 0.
4. And I say you don't appreciate
good work, that is what.
This is fantastic,
with a simple primitive Bohr model
and two minor corrections to zoom
into condensed matter and give this
value. Where is that going to be?
0.02 south of what? It is going to
be here. This is where that lies.
This distance here is the 0.02
electron volt difference.
You're 0.02 electron volts below
the conduction band.
You are not down here.
This is valence. You are up top.
And the electron is sitting in
there because that's the ground
state. And now you are saying,
well, that is really great, Sadoway.
Now you have an electron sitting in
an orbital. How are you going to
get it up to here?
I have an answer for that.
But first look at this. I couldn't
resist this derivation.
I said what about the radius of the
orbit? How far is that electron
away from the phosphorus?
Is it in tight?
Is it moving around like this or is
it way, way out here?
Doesn't that intrigue you?
It sure intrigues me. Here is what
I did. I said the r1,
the radius of this ground state was
going to be given by the Bohr radius
times the modified dielectric
constant divided by the modified
mass. And when you plug in the
numbers you get 30 angstroms.
We say I don't know what the
silicon-silicon distance is.
Well, what do you think it is?
You know it has to be on the order
of a couple of angstroms.
If you compare that, the
silicon-silicon distance is 2.
5 angstroms. This electron is way,
way zooming around. Fantastic what
we have learned here.
Now let's look at this.
We have an electron sitting in this
energy level down below.
Now what happens?
How do I get this thing to move out?
What am I going to do to make it
move out? What do I have?
I know that the energy is 0.
2. But how do I compare this energy
with the thermal energy?
E thermal is on the order of 0.
25, one-fortieth of an eV. The
thermal energy is so high at room
temperature that it is
able to promote these.
And, by the way,
if the Bohr model works for ground
state, what would happen if I were
to blow this up?
Can you imagine,
if this is the conduction band,
I get all of the energy levels. I
get the whole Bohr energy state here.
I get ground state n equals two,
n equals three all the way up. And
now I have enough energy,
from thermal energy, to take all of
these electrons,
because each one of these comes in
because it is a separate phosphorus
and they are far enough apart,
they are separate states. All of
these can get promoted.
What do we call this action?
If I take a ground state electron
in hydrogen and I get it right out
of all of this set of energy levels,
what do we call that process, we
take that electron and we throw it
out of the system?
Ionization. That is exactly what
the electrical engineers call this
process. They call the thermal
excitation of the donor electrons
ionization. For all intents and
purposes, because E thermal is on
the order of this E of the donor
electron, we can assume complete --
And I am going to use the electrical
engineering term here because I
think I am still teaching at an
engineering school,
complete ionization of donor
electrons. This is fantastic.
They are all ionized. Now, last
day I said that the total number of
electrons in the conduction band
would equal the number of electrons
from the host silicon due
to thermal excitation.
Plus it is going to be the number of
electrons from the impurity
phosphorus.
And we know this requires Eg on the
order of about 1.
eV. So very few of these are
contributed. There is almost no
promotion of electrons from the
valence band to the conduction band
to leave holes.
This is vanishingly small at room
temperature in silicon.
Whereas, here, I am going to put in
quotation marks,
the ionization energy is on the
order of the thermal energy,
we get all the electrons from here.
And so in such a material we say
that the electrical properties are
essentially those from
the impurities.
We send this to zero and say that
such a material exhibits "extrinsic
behavior." Why is it extrinsic?
Because the electrical behavior of
the silicon is governed by the
impurities that we introduced into
the silicon. Extrinsic behavior.
Or, let's call it dopant. I am
going to use the word dopant and
impurity interchangeably.
It is dopant-dependent. And this,
of course, depends on how much we
put in.
But the typical levels that we put
in are great enough that they swamp
the value that you get from thermal
excitation. In doped silicon,
you neglect thermal excitation and
you calculate the carrier population
in the conduction band based on how
much phosphorus you put in.
Every phosphorus gives you a
contribution. And,
just to complete the definition,
the undoped material, that is to say
highly pure silicon exhibits
intrinsic behavior.
In other words,
it behaves as pure silicon should
behave. An intrinsic semiconductor
is one that has impurity levels so
low that they do not manifest
themselves. An extrinsic
semiconductor has impurity levels
high enough that we can perceive the
action of those impurity levels.
We can say, in this material, that
n that are generated from the
impurity or the dopant are greater
by far than the n from the
host material itself.
Or, if you like,
the number of electrons from the
dopant are much greater than the
number of electrons from thermal
excitation. It all comes out to say
then that the number of electrons
that are up in the conduction band
are much greater than the number of
holes in the valence band.
Because, if the impurity levels are
dominating what comes out of the
host, then that means if there is
hardly any of the electrons that
came from thermal excitation there
are hardly any holes.
Now the number of electrons far
exceeds the number of holes,
so this material is not net neutral.
We do not say that n equals p
because the number of electrons in
the conduction band is far greater
than the number of holes.
And so we call this material,
it is extrinsic, and electrical
engineers refer to the type of
carrier that is dominating
its electrons.
And electrons,
when I went to school,
were negative, so this is an n-type
semiconductor.
Extrinsic n-type.
We altered the electrical
properties of silicon by introducing
high level of supervalent.
In other words, phosphorus,
five is greater than four, so
supervalent dopant leads to
n-type semiconduction.
And now we can do it all over again.
What can we do? I'm not going to
drag you through it.
This is something you can do at
home or wherever you like to work.
Repeat with subvalent impurity or
subvalent dopant.
For example, boron.
What would happen if we were to
introduce boron here?
Boron goes into the space and
substitutes, but boron is Group 13
or Group III. Boron only has three
valence electrons,
so it fills one, two,
three. Boron is electropositive.
It is sitting there. It wants to
form the bond.
How do we handle this situation?
What do we do in order to balance
the fact that this is lacking one
electron? Where is the electron
inventory in this crystal?
Where is the electron store?
If I go shopping for electrons,
where is the only place I can find
them? They are here.
They are in the bonds.
That is to say, they are in the
valence band. What will happen is
we will rip an electron out of the
valence band and move it over to
here. And, when we do that,
what happens if I take an electron
out of here? What is left behind?
A hole. Let's generate a hole.
Every time I introduce a subvalent
impurity, I call for an electron out
of the valence band and generate a
hole. And where is that hole going
to lie? We can go through the same
analogy and we will find that the
energy level of that hole is sitting
just above the valence band.
But the electrons are sitting in
the valence band,
so how do I get the electrons out of
the valence band up into this level?
Thermal excitation.
And guess what this energy
difference is.
It is on the order of the thermal
energy, and so I get thermal
ionization of the valence electrons
up into this level.
This level is a place where
electrons go. It accepts electrons.
It is called the acceptor level.
So now we have this configuration.
Conduction band, valence band,
subvalent impurity.
This is not to scale,
of course. This is on the order of
0.02 eV. And this is called the
acceptor level.
We get thermal excitation leaving
holes behind. Thermal excitation
promotes the electrons up to here
and leaves behind holes.
Every time I put in a subvalent
impurity the result is a hole,
so I can control the hole population.
And the same thing will happen,
if you go through this analogy what
will happen? N will no longer equal
p. Instead, the number of positives
is going to exceed the number of
negatives. Now ne will be much less
than nh. N will be less than p.
And so this material will be
rendered a positive conductor.
It is going to be dominantly hole
conduction.
So this is now an extrinsic p-type
semiconductor.
What is the template here?
Subvalent dopant calls for
electrons, generates holes and makes
a p-type semiconductor.
That is amazing.
Now I can take these and make a
sandwich out of these things.
I can do this. This is all silicon.
I could dope this side with
phosphorus. Let's say the right is
phosphorus doped and the left side
is boron doped.
That means the left side will be
p-type, the right side will be
n-type. And what do I have here?
I have a p-n junction. I have a
solid state rectifier.
If I put an AC signal in here,
I get rectification. This is the
solid state. It is fantastic.
I have been talking about elemental
semiconductors,
but these are found not only in
elements. This is just leftover
from last day.
We saw this last day.
You can have compounds that are
semiconductors.
So far we talked about just Group
IV.
We talked about silicon and
germanium. Tin is very,
very mildly semiconducting,
but these are the two workhorses.
And, in fact, it is dominantly
silicon. But now,
look, you can take Group III and
Group V and make covalent compounds.
And they, too, have band gaps on
this interval.
We have an entire palette here that
we can paint on.
For example, let's look at this
homologous series with aluminum
antimonide 1.52 electron
volts band gap.
Aluminum nitride 6.
. Aluminum nitride is an insulator.
It is a very strong material. We
use it in my lab as a refractory.
It resists high temperature
corrosion. Now,
what is going on?
The difference in electronegativity.
These are covalent bonds,
greater difference in
electronegativity,
higher bond energy.
And that occurs in all of these
columns as you go up.
So an increase in electronegativity
difference is an increase in bond
strength, and an increase in bond
strength means an increase
in band gap energy.
And some of these are really
interesting. Indium antimonide has
a band gap of about two-tenths of an
electron volt,
which means that its absorption edge
is 7 times 10 to the minus 67
micrometers, which puts it in the IR.
And this is one of the materials
that would be used as a sensor for
night vision. Because what are you
really sensing when you are looking
at night? You are sensing heat.
You don't see the human body. You
see the heat coming from
the human body.
If everything is cold then there is
no delta T and you don't see
anything. Over here,
cadmium sulfide is 5 times 10 to the
minus 7. That is right smack dab in
the middle of the visible.
When I was a child my father had a
35 millimeter camera.
It had a cadmium sulfide light
meter, and we would match the needle
with the incoming radiation and
cadmium sulfide.
Well, I never understood why it was
cadmium sulfide until I understood
band gap. And, obviously,
there it is.
You can also think about what
happens if you are photographing
something that is dominantly red and
your light meter is parked in the
middle of the yellow?
You wonder why your photographs are
overexposed. Think about that some
time. Now, the last thing I want to
tell you is that not only do you
have solid semiconductors,
you have liquid semiconductors.
And when silicon melts, it is not a
semiconductor.
Silicon melts,
the band gap collapses and molten
silicon behaves as a liquid metal.
But, for example,
something like cadmium telluride,
which is useful in night vision, as
a solid has a band gap on the order
of 1.45 electron volts.
As a liquid, it still has a band
gap. It is about 0.
electron volts. It is parked down
in the infrared.
And the transition metal oxides
also do this. Liquid titania is
dominantly an electronic conductor.
Not an ionic conductor because its
band gap is parked there.
And this is of interest to some of
the work in my lab where we are
looking at trying to set the stage
for lunar colonization where you
would want to get oxygen out of the
surface of the moon.
The surface of the moon is not made
out of green cheese,
I am sorry to tell you.
It is made dominantly of iron oxide
and titanium oxide.
That is why it is so brilliantly
white. It is titania.
It is 50% oxygen but tightly bound.
And, if you want to electrolyze the
moon, you have to somehow repress
this liquid semiconduction.
That is a topic of research.
This is probably a good place to
stay. And what we are going to do
next day is we are going to start
onto the treatment of solids and
crystal. But I don't want a lot of
moving. It is 11:47 and we still
have a few minutes.
Let's see. What do we want to talk
about?
We will move past this.
We will get to this next day.
And what I wanted to talk about
today was this image here.
This image is an image of the first
rectifying solid state diode.
This was done at Bell Labs in
Murray Hill, New Jersey in December
of 1947. What you are looking at
here is a piece of single crystal
germanium and the various
leads and so on.
And this was able to perform the
function of a diode.
Now, if I told you that someday
there would be 16 million of those
on a piece of real estate about the
size of your fingernail you would
say that I was crazy.
So what has happened from that day
to this day?
Do you think I could get the
document camera on,
please? I am going to show you
where we have gone.
Let's see. Oh, look at this.
Let's look at Pentium. There is
Pentium. We have a gazillion of
these things underneath the gold
here. Everything is covered in gold
because electrical engineers are
very superstitious.
They get nervous exposing wires so
they plate everything with gold
because they heard somewhere that
gold is chemically inert.
Underneath there is,
well, here you can see that there is
the unit. It is sitting there.
All of this. And here is the
suspension. All of this spider web
is being able to address all of the
various devices.
It started with that first one.
And here is sort of the
intermediate. This is taking the
silicon that I showed you last day.
These are individual devices that
have been put on the silicon through
photolithography.
What are we doing?
We are making masks and we are
conducting these doping operations
to set up the various devices.
And we can make many of them and
then break them up and eventually
put them into something
like this and so on.
That is the result of a long history
of understanding the processing of
devices based upon the chemistry
that started with what?
What started all of this?
The search for octet stability.
Never forget that. That is what
started this, the search for octet
stability. OK. We will
see you on Friday.